[Música]
la edad de jubilación en Francia pasa de
los 62 a los 64 años el consejo
constitucional francés aprobó los puntos
clave de la impopular Reforma de las
pensiones de Manuel macron los
sindicatos aseguran que la lucha contra
la ley continúa en las calles
al menos cinco muertos y 15 heridos deja
el momento un ataque ruso con misiles en
el este de Ucrania según las autoridades
de kiev además fuentes de inteligencia
británica señalan que las fuerzas
ucranianas han abandonado partes de
bacmut ante el avance ruso en la ciudad
la justicia de Estados Unidos imputa con
transmisión y extracción de información
clasificada al sospechoso de la
filtración masiva de documentos secretos
del pentágono el acusado podría
enfrentar 15 años de cárcel se trata de
un trabajador de la inteligencia militar
que compartió los archivos en un grupo
online ultraconservador
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa y es
para mí un gusto acompañarles abrimos
este Informativo en Francia con una de
las que ha sido la noticia del día y es
que el consejo constitucional aprobó los
puntos clave de la impopular Reforma de
las pensiones de Manuel macron que entre
otras cosas recordemos retrasa la edad
de jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años a
esta hora hay protestas en varios puntos
del país y los sindicatos llaman a
continuar la lucha en las calles
recordemos que el movimiento contra la
reforma cuenta con un apoyo mayoritario
de la sociedad y que desde principios de
año ha unido a millones de franceses en
12 jornadas de huelga general desde
París en nuestra jefa de redacción
Margot loadillón nos amplía
nos encontramos en este momento en la
plaza del hotel de la alcaldía de París
donde Se juntaron unas centenares de
personas después del anuncio del Consejo
constitucional que declaró
constitucional la reforma de las
pensiones del ejecutivo de Manuel macú
dejando de lado algunos puntos pero no
la el aumento de lauda de jubilación de
62 a 64 años en el camino entre el
consejo constitucional y aquí podemos
ver unas bicicletas públicas quemadas
unas basuras quemadas hay
juntas de personas espontáneas que
rechazan esta decisión y sobre todo
además la propuesta de referéndum que se
había hecho justamente sobre este punto
crucial del aumento de la edad ahora
Emmanuel tiene quince días para para
promulgar la ley al parecer lo haría lo
más temprano posible había pedido un de
juntarse con los
interlocutores sociales el próximo
martes ellos recha esta propuesta esta
demanda del jefe de estado no quieren
verse con él Hasta el primero de mayo
cuyo día quieren hacer una marcha enorme
para seguir rechazando esta reforma de
las pensiones entonces habrá que ver lo
que va a seguir con el movimiento social
que puede pasar contra este punto
crucial de la Reforma que los sindicatos
y una gran mayoría de la población
siguen rechazando y seguimos en Europa
pero cambiamos de información porque
como cada 14 de abril día de la
proclamación de la Segunda República
Española en 1931 cientos de personas
salen a las calles de España pidiendo el
fin de la monarquía nuestra corresponsal
en Madrid Marina Colorado nos envió este
informe desde las marchas republicanas
en la capital española
España es un país de tradición
monárquica desde hace más de 550 años
sin embargo en 1873 y 1931 se
proclamaron la primera y Segunda
República Española respectivamente cada
14 de abril en el aniversario de la
última proclamación republicana cientos
de Defensores de este sistema de
gobierno salen a las calles de la nación
aquí estamos reivindicando que el rey no
tenía que reinar en este país no elijo
ni el padre porque cuando se hizo la
constitución en el 78 tenía que haber
habido un referéndum monarquía o
República creemos que ha llegado el
momento de que la ciudadanía pueda
decidir qué tipo de jefe de estado
quiere tener y sobre todo poderlo votar
y no como ahora que no tenemos
posibilidad de votar el jefe del Estado
hombre para empezar porque la
institución
monarquía solo nos cuesta y aparte de
que creo o sea Considero que se ríen de
nosotros en nuestra propia cara Aunque
haya españoles que lo defienden en la
actualidad la monarquía sigue teniendo
buena aceptación Una institución que se
lleva 8,4 millones de euros del
presupuesto general del estado cada año
y que se ha visto salpicada en los
últimos años por los casos de corrupción
y blanqueo de capitales del rey emérito
Juan Carlos I que desde 2020 viven
emiratos árabes Unidos desde Felipe vi
buena no puedo opinar buena
del otro rey Juan Carlos lo primero
bueno y lo último catastrófico según el
centro de investigaciones sociológicas
la monarquía está dentro de los últimos
puestos de preocupaciones principales de
los españoles esto frente a la crisis
económica o al paro sin embargo en una
encuesta hecha por medios independientes
un 39% de la población si votaría a
favor de cambiar el sistema hacia una
República en caso de celebrarse un
referendo frente al 31% que se quedaría
con el sistema monárquico actual
vamos ahora con noticias de la guerra en
Ucrania porque al menos cinco personas
murieron y 17 resultaron heridas este
viernes por un ataque con misiles rusos
en las ciudades lobians en el este de
Ucrania esto según informó el gobernador
regional el ataque de las fuerzas de
Moscú impactó contra cinco edificios
residenciales entre otras
infraestructuras en la misma jornada el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin firmó la
ley que permite el reclutamiento
electrónico en un esfuerzo para aumentar
los efectivos del ejército ruso
y en más noticias de la guerra los
servicios de inteligencia británicos
aseguran que tropas ucranianas tuvieron
que retirarse de una zona de bacmut esto
debido a que Rusia habría lanzado un
nuevo ataque a la ciudad tras una mejora
en la cooperación entre el ejército
regular Ruso y el grupo de mercenarios
Wagner
una Sangrienta y larga batalla cuyos
resultado podría estarse definiendo
según los servicios de inteligencia
británicos Y el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia la caída de bacmut Es una
posibilidad las tropas ucranianas
estarían atrincheradas en el oeste de la
ciudad y a punto de retirarse
las tropas de asalto de Wagner llevaron
a cabo operaciones militares de alta
intensidad para capturar barrios en la
parte occidental de la ciudad de bakmut
las unidades de las fuerzas
aerotransportadas que operan en los
flancos apoyan a los escuadrones de
asalto y bloquean los intentos de los
enemigos de entregar munición a la
ciudad
una pequeña ciudad de 70.000 habitantes
antes de la guerra en el este de Ucrania
se ha vuelto el objetivo principal de
las tropas rusas y el grupo paramilitar
Wagner le daría más fácil acceso a urbes
grandes de danés como kramators y
eslobians los soldados ucranianos que
quedan en el frente confirman el asedio
ruso a las líneas de suministro
tenemos barro hasta las rodillas ningún
tanque o automóvil podría pasar no se
puede entregar comida está tan embarrado
cuando Nuestros hombres nos necesitan
llevamos todo a pie durante tres
kilómetros no hay otra manera
en paralelo la atención por una posible
confrontación aumenta pero a más de 9000
kilómetros de bakmut en el mar Pacífico
ruso toda la flota del Pacífico ha sido
puesta en alerta y ha comenzado un
despliegue completo al más alto nivel de
preparación Rusia dice estar preparada
ante cualquier ataque marítimo una
respuesta a los recientes ejercicios
militares conjuntos de Estados Unidos
con países de Asia Pacífico como
filipinas y a la atención en el estrecho
de Taiwán el presidente de Brasil da
Silva culminó hoy su visita a China y
precisamente este viernes se reunió con
el líder con la guerra en Ucrania como
uno de los temas principales del
encuentro ampliamos
Brasil ha recibido positivamente la
propuesta China para Ucrania porque
contiene reflexiones útiles para
conseguir la paz china por su parte
agradecido los esfuerzos de Brasil para
solucionar el conflicto eso reza el
comunicado conjunto emitido a bien
entrada la noche y después de la reunión
entre sí y Lula da silvas partes también
animan a otros países a sumarse a los
esfuerzos tanto china como Brasil se han
postulado como mediadores en la guerra
china lo ha hecho con un plan de 12
puntos que pide el inmediato alto el
fuego Sin condiciones previas Brasil por
su parte con la creación de un grupo de
países neutrales en el que además de
Brasil y China también estarían India o
Indonesia que empujarían a la mesa de
negociaciones a Rusia y Ucrania ambos
planes han sido ignorados tanto por
Estados Unidos como por Europa que
defienden la propuesta de zelensky como
la única vía de solución al conflicto
esta Cumbre ha subrayado la creciente
brecha entre occidente y el mundo gente
es seguro que no habrá gustado en
Estados Unidos porque Brasil se ha
alineado en varios asuntos con china
Lula visitó la sede de la tecnológica
china Huawei fuertemente sancionada por
Estados Unidos y también la sede del
banco de los brics o economías
emergentes donde lanzó una andanada
tremenda contra la hegemonía del dólar
en el mundo se preguntó por qué no
podían elegir una divisa diferente para
sus intercambios comerciales Lula antes
de reunirse con sí prometió que ningún
país iba a prohibir a Brasil que
siguiera mejorando sus relaciones con
China y la Corte Suprema de Brasil
ordenó al expresidente Jair bolsonaro a
que testifique ante la Policía Federal
en un plazo de diez días acerca del
asalto a edificios gubernamentales por
parte de sus partidarios el pasado 8 de
enero el juez Alexandre de moraes falló
a favor de una solicitud presentada por
los fiscales y aseguró que el testimonio
de bolsonaro es una medida indispensable
para el completo esclarecimiento de los
hechos investigados
y la justicia de Estados Unidos imputa
con cargos de transmisión y extracción
de información clasificada al Principal
sospechoso de la filtración masiva de
documentos secretos del pentágono Jack
techera de ser hallado culpable El joven
de 21 años podría enfrentar 15 años de
cárcel el sospechoso que fue arrestado
ayer por el FBI era miembro de la
inteligencia de la guardia nacional
aérea en Massachusetts trabajaba en una
base militar de donde habría sacado los
archivos clasificados además era el
líder de un grupo online de Gamers
ultraconservadores religiosos y amantes
de las armas donde publicó por primera
vez los documentos que en su mayoría
hacían referencia a la guerra en Ucrania
el fiscal general de Estados Unidos se
pronunció sobre el caso
el departamento de defensa está
liderando un esfuerzo importante ahora
para evaluar y revisar la seguridad
nacional implicaciones y lo más
importante realizar una revisión de los
métodos de acceso rendición cuentas y
procedimiento de control que tiene el
departamento para que algo así Nunca
vuelva a suceder no se trata solo de
llevarse documentos a casa eso es por
supuesto ilegal en sí mismo se trata de
la transmisión tanto de la retención
ilegal como de la transmisión de los
documentos todo el mundo sabe aquí que
los documentos al final fueron
transmitidos
y continuamos en Estados Unidos porque
en un fallo procesado de forma urgente
la Corte Suprema mantiene temporalmente
el acceso a la píldora abortiva
mifepristona la decisión responde a la
apelación por parte del fiscal general a
sentencias de tribunales inferiores que
habían querido restringir este
medicamento que sirve para realizar la
mitad de todos los abortos en Estados
Unidos tras este fallo urgente la Corte
Suprema de mayoría conservadora
analizará la cuestión en detalle casi un
año después de haber derrocado la
sentencia de raw versus White que
protegía el derecho al aborto a nivel
Federal de hecho estas mis mas semana
del estado de Florida prohibió la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo Más
allá de las seis semanas
y la misión Juice que buscará vida en
las lunas de Júpiter fue lanzada con
éxito desde la estación europea en curum
ubicada en la Guyana Francesa se espera
que el recorrido hasta llegar al gigante
del sistema solar dure unos 8 años
de camino a Júpiter va a la Sonda
espacial europea Just que despegó con
éxito a bordo de la nave espacial
arianne 5 desde el puerto espacial kurú
en la guayana francesa
este lanzamiento marca el comienzo de un
ambicioso viaje para descubrir los
secretos de los mundos oceánicos
alrededor del planeta gigante Júpiter en
más de una década la misión recorrerá
6.600 millones de kilómetros y buscará
posibles aguas congeladas en tres de sus
lunas Europa calisto y ganímedes es una
fase de crucero muy larga por lo que
Júpiter está cinco veces más lejos del
sol que nosotros entonces necesitamos
ocho años para viajar Júpiter y no
podemos ir a una trayectoria directa
tenemos que hacer sobre vuelos para
ganar velocidad Así que vamos por la
tierra por Venus y la tierra la tierra
nuevamente hasta que finalmente llegamos
a Júpiter
descrita como una hazaña espacial jus
intentará entrar en alrededor de
ganímedes ninguna nave espacial orbitado
jamás una luna que no sea la nuestra
ganímedes en sí es una luna enorme es la
luna más grande del sistema solar es
incluso más grande que Mercurio
es como un planeta pequeño tiene un
núcleo de hierro como la Tierra
tiene agua debajo de la superficie de
hielo por lo que asumimos que en
realidad hay algo así como seis veces
más agua que en la tierra
según la NASA Júpiter posee 80 lunas por
lo que los astrónomos lo consideran un
sistema solar propio hasta 2031 los
científicos podrán empezar a resolver la
gran duda que asalta la humanidad hay
vida en otros planetas más allá de la
Tierra
Muchísimas gracias por su atención Nos
despedimos por ahora pero enseguida
volvemos
[Música]